by the way a listener wrote in i'm still
on the fan mail here now that gary
doesn't have to meet with howard face to
face in the studio does he still have
the psychological issue of needing to
clear his throat and i'm going to tell
you he doesn't clear his throat at all
anymore
really that's not true
oh really you don't hear it i have a
cough button so
i still clear my throat all the time so
it might not be psychological it might
be something else oh well that sucks for
the air that they gave
gary the kill switch because i like
hearing gary clear his throat i mean i
hate it and i love it it's funny the
thing that used to drive me crazy is
that i'd be talking to gary and i'm
eating my breakfast because i got to get
ready for the show and i come running in
and i'm trying to walk down breakfast i
think gary would go you know hey how and
all of a sudden you'd go
in the beginning it was so loud i was
just like i'm going to throw up i'm
going to just vomit
it's so disgus i mean i hear things
rattling around in his head not even
like i wonder what's rattling around but
i asked again what should i do finally i
said to gary gary do you mind leaving
the room
when you clear your throat because i'm
going to throw up
you've got something going on man well
you're constantly and it was like you
know
and then he'd start talking to me and
every once in a while i'd hear him go
like that
yeah yeah
even it's like this
yeah like will would be telling me
you'll run down to this that the other
thing and all of a sudden you know hey
so we had this idea and you're here
and i go does this guy always make it
about himself like can he not take the
focus off of himself for a five seconds
i'm talking now why does he have to
clear his throat yeah like like just sit
there with that [ __ ] in your throat and
don't uh make any noise i love how you
think that that's making it about me
of course it is you're like so dying to
talk that you have to make some kind of
noise you have a tremendous verbal drive
and you when you're standing there you
have you're like
[Laughter]
but it is like a morse code going on
underneath it was like a whole other
show going on you know
i think gary's sending out an sos
gary didn't used to go to a green room
too and try to lock the door so nobody
could hear it poor gary so he went into
the green room for a private session yes
he would try and you know remove himself
from the office and nobody could goof on
him but we could all still hear it you
heard it right through the door
absolutely there's no stopping that
right
hey
so right before she would go you know we
would all go in the morning meeting
and every everyone will walk into the
meeting and gary what's the nice trail
behind
i'm sorry
the door be closed and you start
coughing you know clearing his throat
and then go in and following everyone
else
and you know what it is gary becomes
your obsession you know it's there's a
whole thing going on so you can't
concentrate on anything but gary because
gary thinks you're not paying attention
but you are
because it's fascinating and that's what
happens to me i'm fascinated by gary and
all the movements
and when he starts you know
so jd your experience was you're going
walking into the meeting gary would fall
behind like a guy on a hike you know he
gets lost
yeah
and he would drop back thinking that his
throat clearing wouldn't be heard which
is absurd he would wait for the door to
close like everyone else would walk in
the door would close he'd stay back for
a second clear his throat and then go
into the studio with everybody
and you observe that ritual you like it
yes i i saw that multiple times
it's all truthful there's not a lie
being told yet
right i felt bad for him every time
because i knew what was going on
after he had done all the other clearing
yeah like he'd do a whole clearing all
morning but then just as the door was
shutting gary would hang back and do one
final
and then of course the second he'd come
in you go uh both
you have no idea you want to know the
truth the initial clearing would start
in the car
once i got on the west side highway
sometimes i would just talk in the car i
would go like okay everything's good
today to make sure that it was clear but
then somehow i'd get to work and it
would be unclear again
that settles it everyone back to the
office starting tomorrow
[Music]